[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
hey
[Music]
all right lee lee uh where'd you grow up
where you from originally
pinyon arizona and you're in navajo
what is danae the name means the people
because um carson gives us that name
uh navajo that's that means thieves
but so we don't we know we get offended
about that
when we call navajos oh yeah yeah
so it's like it's like rather it's like
a derogatory term for
for your people yeah interesting
tell me about your childhood you had
both your parents as a kid
yeah there was um 13 of us
my dad was always an alcoholic and
my mom she was a
she stayed home she was a true mother to
to us and
they all passed away though my grandpa
white water his name is totally
means white water so
we were raised by him and my
my grandma too you know her name was
cupfinger but like goody that's what it
means black goodie
cut finger how would you how would you
describe your childhood
i would like i was sent
sent to boarding school when i was seven
years old
seven years old they put me in boarding
school because
my mom couldn't afford to feed us
and we were barely making it by i guess
of course there was 13 of us you know
and
she sent us to boarding school
in chinle arizona
that's where i'm mostly like um
i've got traumatized mentally and
physically
in my mind to hear that um how they
treated us
what kind of stuff would go on
of course mother station of course
just beat the [ __ ] out of us
every day every morning you know it was
sort of like a military style kind of
[ __ ] you know
and this was a foster home run by
it's a chinle boarding school a boarding
school it was run by
government it was run by
caucasians or indians or no
oh by white people
and from there i tried to move up to
where that um i wanted to move on you
know so
and then i i went home and then my mom
was there and
she put me on placement
with uh um lds
missionaries came around to our home to
where that they were
certainly rick um recruiting or whatever
the heck you would call it you know
they wanted some people to
you know little little kids to go to
school on
on placement placement program
lds
anyway i went to school down marinci
pima
fort thomas and thatcher way down in the
southern area of the state
in arizona after i came back
after i came back i decided to do
something with my life
so i just you know voluntarily
went into
military
did that
this is sort of like late night
really
i still have nightmares about that
though
that was afghanistan
yep
after i got out of there
my life hasn't been the same
then i lost my mom
lost everybody even my son you know
so i just i didn't want the streets
you'd be on the streets for how long i
say for about
three years now
your son was grown yeah he stood he was
37 when he passed
he passed away how did he die
i don't know what they say is is a heart
failure
heart failure that's right
he died in minnesota he was an iron
worker
very iron worker
like those tall buildings like you know
stories and stories
high and he was a good young kid
to me i miss listening a lot
every day 24 7 i would say
i miss them a lot yeah so alcohol is
is your is your is your drug now
i don't do any any other than alcohol
like drugs meth or you know marijuana or
anything
i i just think mitzvah depends to
dependency of
to to keep occupied
in my mind toward that
once it wears off i i start thinking
i just
get emotional that's what i do
but alcohol is it helps me
i don't know how that is but it helps me
what is what drink do you go to for
usually
vodka or vodka right yeah in the porter
yeah vodka seems popular with the indian
population here
in germany yeah and then
this it's just you know it makes it
makes me happy and then i
actually out on the street i can
relate to what
people feel all these people are hurt
on the streets they've been hurt one way
or the other you know
one way or another and we we get along
with each other
we we like you know
we back each other up you know we
support each other
do you know your friends on the street
yep yes
this is this is all it is street people
homeless and
we know what we want you know and just
keep drinking the alcohol
native americans seem to have a
susceptibility to uh
to alcoholism it seems right it's
something genetic it seems
it it would be it it is it
has run in my family your dad yeah
my dad my grandpa
i mean my grandpa used to make a run on
a horseback all the way from pinyon into
winslow
just to get through casino and then he
used to
come home with it and he used to sell
and i remember those back in my younger
days
that's what they used to do and
this is like
our lives ain't easy
if you come down to if you come down to
why all the trees has been
broken 1868 treaties
you know what about that i don't you
don't
they've been broken
and all the laws that's going on now to
her that um
to my understanding to like
okay you you
the history books science mathematical
and all this history okay social studies
and all that
how come they don't they don't have it
written down there
in the book the word that they don't
teach what they did to us
how come they don't have that how come
they don't teach that
like cutting the the long walk
the first summoner that they did to us k
carson
he cut up breasts of young ladies
he he killed young ladies
how come this dead son in history how
come they don't
teach that in history how come it's not
some social studies
why is it that they don't bring that up
now all of these
minerals and environmental issues that
they have
now i was
standing rock and cannonball
to protest minnie wichoni
water is life
i stand against that all uranium and all
these drillings that are going on now
there's just contaminating us we can't
even have spring water to connect
contaminate all that
we have no right no more even our plants
even occurring
even all the corn fields we can't grow
anything anymore
because of the kind of contamination
they have coal mines
they have all this thing going on
so there you have my story
you feel like the american indian has
been short-changed
by the white man don't you i mean it's
pretty clear that it's been going on for
many years right forever
are you what is the what is the religion
that now that your
that your people follow is it it's not
christianity we don't want
we don't have well are you a religious
man
yeah i'm tradition
we don't believe in christianity or you
know
we were put to three schools but they
tried it and they very influenced us
to where that um they wanted us to
believe in that but
we always come back don't want to own
traditional ways of life you know
so what do you what do you believe
i mean do you believe in a god we don't
have a god
i don't even know who god is
or jesus or mary or all that
we have a home they call it just on this
day
that's that's that's our belief
what it means is it's you who
who has to believe
in yourself
don't depend on anybody else but accept
yourself
your belief is this corn pollen
white corn yellow corn
then we offer that in the morning
to live another day thankful for another
day
thankful for that we live still
is there racism against the uh native
americans
here in new mexico from of course it's
bad isn't it every border
just recently i heard there was another
incident that happened in farmington
they're really racist over there they
just
you know beat up native peoples out in
the streets
you know in flagstaff
paige winslow ho
broke here in gallup too
very very racist people
but we try to stick up for you know
for each other and try to save her you
know
try to save ourselves for all the from
all this
and surviving on the streets here in new
mexico it's got to be very cold in the
winter
you know what they say it keeps your
body warm
the alcohol the whole
can chemically stuff like hair spray you
know that
so you won't freeze that's what they use
and to keep the virus away
cove it nighting that's what they do
yeah drink hairspray yeah drink
hairspray
and um perfume and all kinds of
you know rice or even yeah even even
that
they say it don't affect them you see
all these guys walking around
you know and they don't even affect them
in any way
it's just that i guess it's because of
the
how it sanitizes their body
their system immune system yeah
it helps them and keeps that drivers
away i guess
what do you see for the future of your
people
um
hopefully we survive
hopefully we keep our cultural
traditional way of life
hopefully these younger generations
learn
what it means to be native to be
indigenous toward that
they would learn our way of life that
how we brought them up how we survived
how we have been surviving this long
for them to learn our traditional songs
prayers
the offerings that we do the ceremonies
that we do
i hope they catch that on to that so
they can continue with
their lives to work that they could
understand
and then it be passed on to generation
to generation
the word that
all the grandkids would survive
i hope i see that future i don't know
i can't tell you how long i'm gonna live
but that's that's my purse
that's my songs that's that's who i am
all right lee thank you so much for
talking with me and good luck with the
with whatever you do from here
you don't know right thank you very much
you